[Musique]
oh
lorsque l'on pense à la scène à paris on
pense inévitablement aux bateaux mouches
qui sillonnent le fleuve transportant
des milliers de touristes ébahis
mais très bientôt on pourra voir de
drôles d'engins qui ressemble plus à de
petits vaisseaux spatiaux cas de
vénérables péniche propulsés par des
moteurs électriques
la cie bobos comme l'appellent ses
concepteurs s'élève lors de
l'accélération hors de l'eau grâce à des
arcs de fibre de verre immergé voilà
lille est en fait les humains ont
inventé les voitures et non on a imaginé
donc de désengorger le centre ville du
monde entier on en se déplaçant sur
l'eau en se réappropriant ses fleuves
sur un mode zéro bruit 0 vague et zéro
pollution
venez passer du rêve à une réalité
aujourd'hui
ce nouveau mode de transport soutenu par
la mairie de paris devait faire son
apparition il ya six mois mais il s'est
heurté à la réglementation qui interdit
aux véhicules maritime de dépasser la
vitesse de 18 kilomètres à l'heure sur
la scène or ces engins peuvent aisément
atteindre 50 kilomètres à l'heure
d'autres villes dans le monde
s'intéressent à cette idée
aujourd'hui on a vu les drêches de
rotterdam en hollande
comme cette dame qui regardent le
dossier on à genève zurich paris en
amont d'accord centre européen avec les
maires de saint tropez chelsea on ne
connaît pas encore la date de leur mise
en service
mais deux exemplaires de ces engins
futuristes vont sillonner le fleuve lors
d'une rencontre internationale sur la
haute technologie qui se tiendra dans
les prochains jours à paris il si
frédéric nicoloff radio-canada mots rien
[Musique]